les nouvelles encourageantes sont rares
depuis deux semaines mais celle ci est
digne de mention en afrique du sud là où
la première vague mondiale de code
micron a déferlé il y a tout juste un
mois la situation s'améliore rapidement
dans l'ensemble du pays on observe une
réduction de plus de 40% des cas en
l'espace d'à peine une dizaine de jours
et dans la province de gauteng la plus
sévèrement touchée par ce nouveau
variant les diminutions est encore plus
remarquable
plusieurs facteurs pourraient expliquer
ce phénomène dont le respect des règles
sanitaires
je pense qu'ils ont activé des mesures
sanitaires probablement de façon très
efficace et c'est comme quand on ferme
le robinet alors le puits d'eau qui
coule la population pourrait également
être mieux protégés contre la coved en
général que ne l'était durant les vagues
précédentes
si bien que le variant même très
contagieux aurait moins d'occasions pour
se répandre ses claques on a beaucoup de
gens qui sont
vaccinés ces claques en afrique sud
surtout il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
déjà été infectées donc une protection
qui est causé par l'infection préalable
il faut aussi signaler que le nombre
total de spitz alisation et de cas
sévère causée par au micron en afrique
du sud et - vie qu'on appréhendait il ya
un mois
une nouvelle étude en provenance du
royaume uni venant même sens le risque
d'hospitalisation serait jusqu'à 70 %
moins élevés avec le variant au micron
qu'avec le rien delta évidemment chaque
pays représente une situation
particulière mais quand même beaucoup
d'experts suivent l'évolution de la
vague sud africaine avec intérêt je
pense que c'est possible que
l'augmentation très rapide au micron
qu'on a vécu ici au québec et au canada
suivie par une diminution très rapide
c'est ce qu'il faut espérer ici normand
grondin radio canada montréal